yeah so um yeah thanks for inviting me
to speak to you uh I'm Dan McQuillen I'm
a lecturer in creative and social
Computing at Goldsmith University of
London and I also recently wrote a book
called resisting AI an anti-fascist
approach to artificial intelligence
and what's the high level thesis of the
book very much that if we don't pay
attention I AI will lead to an
increasing Amplified series of harms but
that there are alternatives you know I
originally set out to write a book
called AI for the people because I
want to promote the idea of Technology
adding social value and making Better
Lives possible but I ended up calling it
resisting AI because
the kind of AI we have I think needs to
be resisted and we need something
radically different wonderful let's just
get a shot at the book
[Music]